قوس خطر جديد في اوروبا فالقاره العجوز
تعيش اسوا موجه جفاف لها منذ 500 عام حسب
ما انتهى اليه تقرير لمركز لبحوث المشتركه
التابع لمفوضيه الاوروبيه تعود ظاهره
الجفاف في اوروبا الى التغير المناخي ما
ادى الى تراجع ملحوظ في هطل الامطار
وارتفاع في درجات الحراره شهدتهما القاره
هذا الصيف والنتيجه تراجع منسوب المياه في
اشهر انهار القاره حتى ان بعض تلك الانهار
جافه او يكاد فهذا نهار دوار اطول انهار
فرنسا وقد بات طيعا امام عبور الاشخاص في
مناطق محدده منه والمشهد ذاته في دول مثل
المانيا واسبانيا والبرتغال وايطاليا
وبريطانيا ما استدعى اعلان حاله طوارئ في
بعض بلدان القاره لخطوره الوضع يبدو ان
موجه الجفاف هذه مستمره لاجيال ولي عقود
قادمه براي خبراء بيئيين وعدد من الدراسات
المتخصصه والنتيجه تعثر المنتجات الزراعيه
وانتاج الطاقه الكهرومائيه ولا يبدو ان
الغداء مشرق على اي حال اذ يرى خبراء
المناخ ان الاسوء لم ياتي بعد ويرجحون ان
يصبح الجفه في قاره اوروبا اكثر حده عام
2050 هي اذا موجه جفاف غير مسبوقه
وتكلفتها على اقتصاد دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
وبريطانيا قد تصل الى 65 مليار دولار
سنويا حسب دراسه متخصصه في هذا المجال